normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
cnr.com who's that bill Mah reveals to
Roseanne Bar he's never heard of MK
Ultra or the world economic Forum this
is such an amazing example an amazing
example of the ignorance that persists
among liberals and let me play for you
this video Roseanne educating Bill Mah
in a hilarious way I don't remember this
no you blocked it out MK
Ultra who's that that's the mind control
program you're under Bill MK Ultra yeah
doesn't even remember who's but who's
CLA Schwab the head of the
wef what's
that Google
it yo this is why I'm gonna be
completely honest Bill Maher won't come
on this show and I I I I I think there's
a there's a reason why liberals and
leftists avoid this show because look
Roseanne I mean she knows what Mk Ultra
is she knows what the world economic
forum is in this video she didn't even
say much about it but Bill Maher has no
idea these people they live on the tip
of the iceberg up top above the surface
level and we're all scuba diving so we
see all the dirt the grime and the
horrors of the deep
and people like Bill Mah are standing up
top looking around like it's just water
y'all are crazy nothing but water like
you know down there there's skulls and
other really awful disgusting things
Roseanne gets to hang out with Bill Mah
but this is it this is a good example of
where Liberals are at they have no idea
what's going on they don't pay attention
they don't
care yeah I think that's true I think
what I like right now is like rosean bar
is one of these celebrities that's sort
of toying the line between several
things it was like theovon had Tucker
Carlson on his show and I love it
because he's just like a comedian he's
making observation he has Mass Appeal on
the other hand Tucker is completely
political and everything is and they
have this interesting conversation uh
Rose andar confronting bill over here
who's like hearing the words MK Ultra
and glitching he has no idea what's
going on is extremely funny for I I
don't know an endless number of reasons
but also because it's sort of showing
that more moderate people are aware of
these things and I think that is not
what liberal entertainment expected I'm
having a hard time believing he didn't
know what Mk aler was like is he is Bill
a master troll like does he pret is he
great at fainting ignorance no the
famous clip of course is when uh Dennis
Prager was on and mentioned tampons in
the men's room and bill was like no
that's for their girlfriends come
on and Dennis was desperately
desperately trying to inform these
liberals of actual things that were
happening and they all just laughed like
a bunch of cackling I wonder if
Bill adopted cynicism because his show
got shut down after 911 because he spoke
out so harshly against it against like
the response to War I don't know exactly
what he said he said something about so
saying not hating the terrorists like
thinking everybody's you know yeah and
now he's like uh oh if I speak out of
line again they're going to cancel me
again so I've got to always be like oh
really I didn't know the first heard his
show this his podcast do you think
afterwards he fell down like the
craziest Google Rabbit Hole of like
looking all of this stuff up he's not
hasn't left his office for three days
he's totally like calling Roseanne Bary
like thank you for telling me about this
or you think
I don't think they want to know they
just write us off as conspiracy
theorists and they never look into it
it's interesting but also wouldn't
wouldn't you wonder like this is what I
I find interesting if you're if you're
curious about things you you would look
it up but is it actually just trying to
put your head in the sand and and
pretend none of this is happening well
uh just as an aside for whatever reason
a few minutes ago a house exploded in
Arlington and there's video of it so I
don't think anyone's house
specifically no it was a house exploded
in Arlington so it's like big breaking
news uh the police weing a search
warrant and this house
exploded but uh you know people are
people chatting it but we don't we don't
have any uh details on on why so don't
know what else to tell you about that
but anyway back to the point happened
from like gas leaks right no this was a
search warrant being served to a house
that was barricaded the house then
exploded yeah so anyway billah Bill Mah
is the she called him MK Ultra
that's what basically Bill Mah is the
propaganda grift machine for the the
above surface level narrative machine he
is the Mocking Bird yeah but then he
like laughed and then was like what is
that like it's so weird is he even
participating in this conversation yeah
they talk about the bank for
international settlements and he's like
what's that and she's like it's the
Swiss bank it's the bank of the the
mother Bank of all central banks the
Central Bank of central banks and he's
like yeah but they're not running the
show Banks I think it's funny that like
you know Ian's bringing up Smedley
Butler and the in the business plot and
I'm like I don't think that has relevant
to well we're we're actually dis like if
it was Bill Mah he'd be like huh imagine
wanting to start a podcast and being
like I've done no research I know
nothing of politics but I'm here to
debate
you okay people listen to that how many
subscribers does he have on his on his
show what is it called what's this show
called um that one is is it like the
Bill Mar show no that like uh I don't
even know the name of critically
uncorrect no I don't know what the hell
he calls it after dark I don't know
that's Dr Drew's Show Club random there
it is Club random all right well let's
take let's let's take a look here at we
got Club random uh podcast and uh we'll
P that hi I'm Bill he's got half a
million subscribers and 840 videos there
it is and let's take a look at his
videos he's got he's got one with Jordan
Peterson 4.1 million that's more for
Jordan Peterson RFK I mean I mean that's
the reality of this it it's it's his
videos are mostly about the guests him
sitting down with Kid Rock probably
interesting because what's happening is
you know actually I take it back it's an
excellent show it's an excellent show it
is dumb guy who doesn't read is educated
by everyone else basically kind of like
Rogan it does kind of no but no but
Rogan Rogan has a good idea a lot about
what he's talking about he calls himself
dumb just so curious like Rogan asks a
lot of really interesting questions
because his mind is going whereas Bill
Mah is sort of like haha I think I'm
supposed to laugh here I haven't watched
a show early so I shouldn't be that
critical uh but it is if there's sort of
a difference I think if you were to sit
down with someone and say I know
absolutely nothing about this please
tell me as much as you can in the next
hour that could be an interesting format
I think because he's sort of a built
personality it comes across differently
you sort of expect him to know more I
guess that's actually you know I'm I'm
I'm probably biased I mean I don't think
I know everything there's a lot I don't
and we bring people on and culture War
especially is is is that but Bill Maher
is remarkably ignorant I mean if you're
going to if you're going to invite
someone on your show to discuss the
merits of some political cause and then
with like in Dennis prager's case laugh
at him it's like no no no no listen
listen Dennis Prager comes on your show
and says they're putting tampons in the
men's room the response I think which
would be reasonable is really they're
really doing that I haven't seen that
let me look that up yeah ignorance lar
is like no you're crazy and now we're
all going to laugh at you ignorance is
acceptable and if you have a smart mind
and you can learn it's actually
invigorating to watch someone that's
ignorant learn the information and no
longer be ignorant but ignorance muddled
with cynicism is just disgusting we've
we've invited bill on this show and I
can recognize why he can't do it does
his own show and he lives on the head of
the country he came out to DC for uh
standup so we again invited him on the
show and the response was he's not
sticking around in DC but you know have
a nice day said okay no problem I get it
so then we said what if we go to La or
wherever you know we go to California
and we will set up for the week and have
Bill on either in the morning or at
night his choice and they said we're not
interested at this time Bill Bill Maher
I I think would end up just sitting
there being like what's that what's that
what's that what's that I don't know
what that means then bill would make
some argument and I'd say actually here
let me Google it for you show them an
article and I'll go oh I didn't know
that the whole show would be him saying
I didn't know that imagine going to Bill
Mah and talking about all the things the
bidens have done he'd be like really no
they didn't I mean if if Bill Mah
actually listened to anyone in this room
or you know what you'll be really great
anyone in the audience right now any we
I could take a random person and sit
them down with Bill Maher and they
probably know more than Bill Maher does
Kings you have to call Bill Mar and help
him out he needs your support well I
have to tell you his viewership is even
worse so I went to be in the audience of
his show when Steve Bannon was on and
was just chitchatting with some of the
folks who are you know huge bill Mah
fans I mean these are the most like dis
genic uninformed people you will ever
see in your entire life so what do they
do like where are these people are they
like working in offices how do they
support themselves how are they not
aware of some of this stuff you you're
not going to know everything about
everything but to be that level of
uninformed seems Seems almost impossible
to me all right I I nominate Marshall
Mushi in chat to debate Bill Mah because
I'm confident that uh additionally um
hype Beast Delo would also be able to
run circles around Bill Mar I think
Bill's his just he's a comedian and his
fans are like comedy fans they're not
like politically initiated it's very
small percentage of the world that
understands anything about politics
you're you're half right like 1% Bill
Mah is a political com commentator his
show he has new new rule section where
he literally talks of culture and
politics he brings on journalists and
writers and this is and and and they
talk about politics and culture and you
know this this this is why we had um
Bannon came on once and told me that I
needed to go on his show and he was like
let me let me reach out to them I was
like I don't want to go on that guy's
show I just I just you know I'll I'll
I'll I'll go on someone else's show and
I'll be respectful to them but
especially with the panel they're all
going to be talking garbage and just
word diarrhea coming out on the desk and
it's going to be like I saw what
happened to Dennis Prager he was the
smartest guy in the room he ran circles
around him and they all laughed at him
bro if I wanted to go into a room and
and say thanks make people laugh I can
easily just go do like a a a a a you
know balloon animal routine at a fairg
ground and get a bunch of people to clap
and cheer for balloon animals if that's
what you're looking for if you want to
have a serious conversation it ain't
going to be with people like Bill Maher
yeah I wonder going into a venue where
people don't understand what you're
talking about and telling the truth and
then looking like an idiot like it's
exhausting it can be very exhausting so
I understand not wanting to go into that
that room of of that rockus crowd and
trying and and he's he has HomeField
Advantage when you're in your own show
right I mean everyone who does the show
is going to say thank you and for the
most part I assume and his producers
going be like you did a great job good
good question and then if the host does
like a side eye then the whole audience
is going to do a side eye because
they're all cult worshippers and then
it's like oh God I got to deal with the
cult no thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 P.M and become a member over at
timcast.net
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time